اب شهيد
هذا جهز والله قبور جماعيه ل تقريبا 35
شهيد
طبعا ليش بتند حال لان طبعا صعب الوصول
الى المقبره على رغم ان المقبره تقريبا لا
تبعد عنا الا بضعه امتار لكن لا نستطيع
الوصول لان قوات الاحتلال قريب من المكان
ربما الذي يصل هناك يرجع
شهيدا خلص خليك
خ 28
تعالوا يلا يلا يا
جماعه يا شباب صلاه
جماعيه وليس مجهولين هول 30 بني ادم عندي
معروفين و مسقين كلهم في المغسله داره
المغسله ولا واحد فيهم مجهول المجهول
يهم اقامه الاهالي هي
المجهوله عشان الحصار اللي فيه وجمع ناصر
الطبي في الايام القليله الماضيه تم دفن
حوالي 150 شهيدا في ساحات مجمع ناصر الطبي
واليوم ندفن باقي الشهداء والمرضى
الموجودين في ثلاجه الم الموتى
وعددهم 30 شهيدا
ومريضا تم دفنهم بسبب عدم تما ذويهم من
الحضور الى المستشفى وكذلك بدات اجسادهم
تتحلل السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله